[Music]
hey you guys
i know this is a weird time
uh
i got a landscaping guy coming he could
be here any minute so if he brings a
doorbell it's something i'm gonna have
to go deal with them jenny can shut the
show down
yeah i didn't actually know that he was
coming or what time he was coming so we
were he's coming and going yeah so we're
kind of like running around trying to
like figure out when we can squeeze the
show in without like too much
interruption yeah but uh so that we
might have to cut this one short yeah
not a big deal though this is a very
simple movie uh it's not a famous movie
um an independent film that really
punches above its weight we saw it again
last night it was it was good real good
um i want to get this one on dvd uh you
can buy it 20 on dvd or you can watch it
free on youtube there's kind of a bad
copy of it up there but
it's got sanskrit
uh or arabic subtitles ourselves and
it's
it's real low resolution so the
some of the scenes had uh computer
graphics and it looked pretty bad and
the costumes don't quite look as good as
they look in hd but
uh this movie here is all story story
and uh acting and world building
um i like this real good a lot it just
kind of kind of reminded me of a little
bit like um
um
almost kind of like duel it's happening
in the desert but between dudes chasing
each other out in the desert uh this
[ __ ] stormtrooper type dudes chasing
this dangerous alien fugitive that got
away from them
and the story starts unfolding you find
more and more about the situation and
a bunch of cat and mouse stuff and
bounty hunters show up and
it's good real good i liked it
well like i said this just goes to show
that you don't need a [ __ ] ton of money
you don't need a [ __ ] ton of
effects or you know cgi or anything like
that to make something that's like
pretty compelling because i'm not
actually sure how much uh this costs to
make nothing from whatever uh yeah it
was like yeah hardly anything yeah now
the guy that made this uh sandy calora
i guess i didn't know this but i guess
he kind of got a a name for himself back
in 2003
and he kind of made the rounds of like
comic-con and he made this
like 30 000
fan film called batman dead end i think
it was animated
uh i saw this one thing where it was
like it was batman fighting the predator
fighting
the thing
i can't remember now but everybody
thought it was just the most awesome
thing ever so and it was like really
lush because he'd spent quite a bit of
money on it for a fan film so he kind of
got really famous from that
so on the back of that he was able to
like raise some money to make this
hunter pray which i think is his first
feature film yeah uh i think it came
2009 2010 somewhere around there it's an
unofficial sequel to enemy mine
pretty much yeah it's it's definitely in
the same universe because they do
actually have a discussion about drax
there aren't any drax in it yeah they
talk about the dream but they talk about
the drax as like another species yeah uh
that's going on i think well the what
are the um the sidonians right or some
of the aliens that are in this but yeah
so the thing is it's kind of hard to
talk about this without spoiling
because there's kind of like a reveal
that happens about 30 minutes in yeah
this movie's not really well known so
we're not going to spoil anything it's
just we're going to say this is a great
movie
oh it's a great little movie punching
way above its weight
it's all story and acting and action
um
really good costumes great
score
really good score it's kind of like a
classic desert
action score almost like something out
of hills have eyes or
yeah like hills have eyes or
uh
what was the other one um it kept for
some reason it kept reminding me of duel
i don't know why just it's it reminds me
of an old 70s
desert western movie but it's in space
it's not on earth it's it's on another
planet
it's kind of like tatooine kind of i
think some of the cinematography was
meant to evoke things like uh
planet of the apes yeah stuff like that
yes um that's right the soundtrack did
sound like planet of the eighth from
what i could think and and that was
intentional like he was definitely
trying to do kind of like a 60s 70s
sci-fi yeah kind of look and feel to it
yeah but like you said it is very much
like enemy mine as well where it's kind
of like enemies on a planet and they're
like you know they're chasing each other
trying to survive on this
in this harsh environment and so it's
kind of similar to that and like i said
they do talk about the drax even though
yeah the the aliens in this are not drax
the costumes are basically armor and
it's real functional it's like something
that soldiers would actually wear you
know be an ex-military myself and uh a
lot of the equipment is you could tell
that it's handmade leather uh some kind
of plastic or
carbon fiber armor
uh they have like a [ __ ] data link up
system where they're talking to ai
computers that can do a bunch of stuff
there's implants
like tracking implants um all kinds of
good
oh and the the armors can dispense drugs
and
steroids to keep you [ __ ] going if
you get if you get wounded
they can do whole like medical
procedures on you but it's it's like
realistic uh uh the us army was actually
interested in that kind of stuff things
that could
suits that if they are perforated would
start like you know dispensing blood
clotting agents and um you know [ __ ]
uh adrenaline and
painkillers
and these guys have all that
they got
cool guns that look like they really
work
um
just the costumes are really well made
the aliens look good real good
uh
it does not look like a cheap movie it
looks expensive
it does actually
i was i was surprised even in little res
you see the free copy on youtube it
looks expensive but i remembered it
seeing it um
on dvd and it looked even better in hd
or you know
as high as definition as dvd went back
in those days which is probably at 7 20.
i think it might have been 70 yeah back
in those days it looked real good
um
some of the armor you can see the kind
of the weathering on it looks like
airbrushing but i think that's just the
the nature of a low resolution copy uh
some of the space scenes look kind of
video gamey but then again i think it's
just this copy because i didn't remember
them
standing out as looking real fake
um when i saw it on dvd
but then again it doesn't matter this is
not that kind of movie it's a kind of
movie it's mostly just about action out
in the desert almost kind of like a
western
it's not dependent on
cgi to be entertaining it's all story
and acting it's got real good acting in
it i'll give it that i think the only
cgi in this is just like the ship's
landing and stuff like that ship's
landing very like uh
uh establishing shots that are happening
in space yeah that kind of thing um he
he has a pistol that fires out a damn
wave of energy oh yeah it's like a
non-lethal pistol
you can shoot it and it shoots out kind
of like a
ball of [ __ ] air i guess
or
and if it hits you it throws you
just knocked your ass down yeah that was
cg like it slapped you like it [ __ ]
punched you
i will say too when you were talking
about the the thing that uh dispenses
the drugs and everything they
essentially the sedonians essentially
have
it's kind of like the ship's computer in
star trek where it's just kind of like a
it's like a woman's voice her name's
clia yeah and she monitors all your [ __ ]
she can like you know tell you where
stuff is and tell you what your heart
rate is each guy has his own
relationship with her too but she's like
the same and i will say too that she is
voiced by
erin gray oh okay yeah she's in a lot of
buck rogers fame of she was on silver
spoons she was actually on the netflix
mystery science theater she was on
reptilicus she's on star trek continues
that's right on star trek continuing
voyages she'll do a lot of the uh fan
films yeah
she seems cool that way yeah but yeah
she does the voice of clia in this one
which is actually quite a big uh part
yeah it's the main character role i just
never see her they're here talking to
her on the head yeah they just talked to
her on the headset uh thank you very
much erin haven't donated for pookie
treats in a while oh thank you thank you
do you hear that pokey
she's crashed out of there by her toy
pile she get into a pile of toys and
just fold it and just where she's like
oh my toys yay
um also i didn't know this either but
like the guy that plays
um
centauri seven yeah his name is damian
poitier
and i think he's related to sydney
probably um
he was actually the first
uncredited uh guy that played thanos in
the marvel cinematic universe
in the avengers in 2012 there's a lot of
good hand-to-hand action a lot of good
kind of realistic small unit military
tactics happen in it so somebody was in
the military who helped write this movie
a lot of the dialogue and the
you know the discipline structure within
between the ranks is is is pretty
accurate for a lot of elite military
um they fight a lot a lot of [ __ ]
fist fights and [ __ ]
and um
it's uh it's kind of hyper macho it's a
hyper macho movie if you like that kind
of [ __ ] women let jenny love it too it's
just uh yeah that's good it's just
badass manly yes but i like it too
yeah desire manly man
badass
from disney from each from different
planets fighting over stuff for high
stakes and they're all different
uh i liked it good movie yeah i mean
basically i didn't even say what the
setup is because like i said i don't
want to spoil too much about it because
there's a couple reveals and the plot
isn't super complicated no but the setup
is that there's a bunch of uh sidonians
and they are
transporting a prisoner who's a who they
say you know he's the last of his kind
or whatever they're transferring them
somewhere and they're shipped there i
don't remember where they're
transferring them to but they're taking
them someplace and their ship crashes on
this uncharted desert planet yeah um and
he's getting away which is actually
mexico they shot that in mexico yeah it
looks good it does it looks it does look
like an alien planet actually he's good
he he's this creature's getting away so
they're trying to track it down
and as the uh
as the story unfolds the captain who's
kind of leading the retrieval mission in
their own they're they're the only
survivors of the crash yeah um
he's kind of holding back information
about this creature and as it kind of
unfolds they all realize that the
mission is a lot more important than
they thought it was yeah it's not just a
fugitive there's a lot more to it
and then it just keeps going and you
keep finding out more and more about
what the hell's going on
and um you learn uh you know each each
character in it has their own character
and their own motivations they're all
good characters
and um you know you just got to see how
it how it goes down
it's good movie
it really is and as i said it's it sucks
that you can't really stream it anywhere
yeah
like i said you can watch it for free on
youtube but it's
i guess it has arabic subtitles on it
yeah um and it's not a real high-res
copy it's watchable
but it doesn't look as good as we've
seen it look yeah um because how did we
see it before i had it on i had a copy
of it on dvd a burnt dvd copy that's
right this is uh where did that go
gone
gone um it the uh
the movie is just kind of like uh
it was a tiny indie film that
didn't get much attention
and just kind of vanished
you can get it on dvd and a blu-ray i
think is special order they want 40
bucks for it on on amazon yeah i put it
on our amazon storefront like but yeah
the dvd is cheaper but yeah you can get
it on blu-ray and it's not a cheap dvd
it's 20 bucks yeah
a cheap dvd's five so but i mean the
collector's item right and nobody's
streaming it so it's worth watching if
you like enemy mine or any kind of
sci-fi action
if you like westerns if you like
[ __ ] if you like the mandalorian
man yeah it gave me that kind of vibe
too like it's kind of like enemy mind
but not like as funny
and it has more action and like just
more fighting in it and kind of like
ambushes and [ __ ] like that so in that
way it was kind of like enemy mind meets
the mandalorians yeah and this predates
mandalorian by many years yeah this was
2010 or maybe 2009 yeah but you can see
a lot of this in mandel you can see a
lot of this in mandalorian
surprise me if jean farves saw this and
went yeah that's a badass maybe so
i didn't really see tone is real similar
yeah
i didn't really see a lot of reviews of
this a couple like i saw a couple dudes
on youtube that had that reviewed it and
a bunch of them did point out like the
enemy mind thing um like i said it's not
tonally
i don't know plot wise it's kind of
similar to enemy mind but tonally it's a
little bit different than that like i
said it's more like mandalorian like the
tone of it and you can i mean you can
i don't want to say that you can tell
it's low budget because there were
because we were watching it last night
there were like a couple shots
that
you know you can tell that they're just
trying to pad out like make it a little
bit longer like here's this guy like
walking along i was like well it looks
nice though it looks nice they were
homage and 70s stuff yeah where you're
walking through the lens flare in the
desert at night you know and to try to
give you them sensation of a passive
passage of time you know yeah i didn't
mind it no it's fine i mean um if the
movie's not overly long so they can do
that and it's a simple story that
keeping you and wondering what the hell
is going to happen it's almost like a
very very long it's like a double kind
of like a double episode of the
mandalorian kind of feels about like
that
yeah that's actually a good yeah yeah
and it's it's kind of a shame that this
didn't get more
traction because
you know it seems like this movie
was i mean for as low a budget as it had
was actually better than some of the
kind of really big
you know super expensive sci-fi movies
um just by having like good characters
and just like a simple story that
actually kind of kept you guessing and
kind of kept you interested in
what exactly was going on because there
you know like you get like revealed
little bits of information about this
mission you know as the time goes on dj
maniac says the the
the batman movie was live action yeah
it's called batman dead end yeah i said
that but i could i for some reason i
thought it was animated okay um
i don't know why i i think i read
something about it somewhere and i think
somebody said it was animated and i was
like but i didn't remember but then i
was watching something else and they
were talking about that guy and that's
kind of how
he got known like in 2003 by making that
because he kind of like upped the game
for fan films yeah sort of thing and i
kind of feel like ooh there goes my
creepy phone again
so is this considered a fan film
or or is it just an indie film i
wouldn't no i wouldn't consider a fan
film you'd have to like take property
yeah you would have to take it like an
ip that was already existing and making
your own [ __ ] in it and you can't like
make money from it because of copyright
this is its own story they like i said
they do bring up the drax yeah from
enemy mines as they could because they
could but there's no drax in it they
just talk about them like they exist out
there you know what i mean and they can
it's an indie film so yeah it's just
like an independent film it's not a fan
film um it does have like homages to
other movies but it's totally its own
thing and it's got its own lore
and you know like i said i think it's
really cool like that somebody is that
you know like so that into the movies
you can make like a really good movie
with hardly anything yeah i give it um i
give it five stars out of five
just yeah it is it's super fun it's just
basically
the end product and knowing what they
paid for that
it's just like
there should be a lot more of these
being made
in terms of this is the way to make
movie yeah you don't need to spend a
bunch of money shot in 18 days just 18
days you don't need a bunch of money
just need a good story and good acting
and people that care about
their craft yeah and this has got good
acting through the whole thing and the
cinematography is really nice too i have
to say the cinematography is like way
like way better than it has any right
being yep um so that's why i would kind
of recommend getting it on dvd or
blu-ray blu-ray yeah if you just want to
see it then yeah you can watch it on
youtube for free but it doesn't look as
good man for first impressions man buy
this
that's what i would think yeah it's just
a shame it's not streaming anywhere why
does it why didn't somebody rent it i
mean amazon prime could rent it or i've
seen like way shittier movies on amazon
prime that's available it's a licensing
problem maybe
i don't know what it is but it's kind of
sad and that's why i mean i'm glad that
you brought it up and what we were
talking about enemy mine because i was
like well we saw it a long time ago and
i remember it being really good and i
was like man we should like clue more
people into that because i think more
people should see it you know yeah
support that kind of like independent
filmmaking i think that's a really good
thing to be doing yeah it it actually
and it and when it ends
it leaves there's an open possibility
for a sequel i wonder if he's ever gonna
make one i mean it's been like 11 years
but it's been like 11 years but it's
happened before that's true
yeah maybe he'd be like i'm gonna circle
back around to that why not yeah
all right so uh i know we've only been
on for like 20 minutes or something but
yeah if you weren't we gotta yeah if you
weren't here at the beginning uh the
reason we were late starting is we had a
workman here and he had to leave and
then he has to come back like to do some
more [ __ ] so he's maybe gonna be like
banging around and stuff i think he's
going to do like landscaping and stuff
too
but he's going to be like i'm going to
have him hang up that spice directly
inside that door too okay so he's just a
regular ass handy so he's going to be
like banging around in the house and
we're not entirely sure when he's going
to be back so we probably should yeah we
should probably cut this short because
he's going to be ringing the doorbell in
a second but uh yeah so uh we'll be back
tomorrow gonna try and do uh 3 p.m
again like usual i think we're going to
watch that uh that movie with the rock
that's on netflix yeah remember we'll
watch that tonight we'll talk about that
by camera what it's called but it looks
funny so uh we'll do that tomorrow so
thanks everybody for dropping by sorry
for the short notice sorry for not being
on that long but yeah we got this dude
coming so uh we will see you guys again
tomorrow afternoon
bye